auch in diesem Jahr wird sie hohe
Verluste einfahren die bundeseigene Bahn
AG der deutschen Sorgenkind stets
unpünktlich jeder dritte Fernzug letztes
Jahr verspätet ihr Schienennetz marode
überlastet wieder DB aus der Misere
helfen die Unionsfraktion versucht jetzt
Weichen neu zu stellen mit einem Entwurf
der die Zerlegung des Konzerns vorsieht
es sind Milliarden im Bundeshaushalt
liegen geblieben die vom Management der
Bahn nicht abgerufen wurden in einer AG
ist das Management verantwortlich wir
hatten keine Möglichkeit als Parlament
und Regierung unmittelbar einzugreifen
und deshalb brauchen wir diese Reform
den Papier zufolge sollen Infrastruktur
und Transportbereich ganz getrennt
werden Netz Bahnhöfe und Energiesparte
sollen in einer Infrastruktur GmbH des
Bundes gebündelt werden bei der Bahn
verblieben nur Fernverkehr Nahverkehr
und Gütertransport so soll das
Verkehrsministerium besseren Zugriff auf
aus neu und Umbau der Schiene erhalten
das heißt wir können direkt sagen wir
geben Milliarden wir erwarten aber auch
dass dafür Gleise Bahnsteige
Barrierefreiheit ordentlich ausgebaut
wird der Fahrgastverband pro Bahn kann
den unionsvorschlägen Positives
abgewinnen uns kommt es darauf an dass
die Infrastruktur gemeinwirtschaftlich
betrachtet wird und dass keiner mehr
anfängt und sagt wir haben hier ein
kostenlosen Faktor von unter 1 der sagt
denn die Strecke darf nicht betrieben
werden oder darf nicht gebaut werden und
das muss darum gehen welche Strecken
brauchen wir für unsere
Verkehrsinfrastruktur wo können und wo
sollen Leute mit der Bahn fahren bei den
Ampel Partnern sorgt der Entwurf für
erstaunte Reaktionen über den Vorschlag
aus der Unionsfraktion kann man sich
einerseits freuen durch den
Erkenntnisgewinn andererseits aber auch
wundern denn zum einen ist es so dass
über drei Bundesverkehrsminister hinweg
die Unionsfraktion die Zeit gehabt hätte
die notwendigen Reformen anzupacken und
das andere ist ein Großteil dessen was
die vorschlagen setzen wir als
Ampelkoalition derzeit schon um
tatsächlich ist im Koalitionsvertrag
längst vereinbart die Infrastruktur
Spaten der Bahn zusammenzulegen wie
genau unter dem Dach der Bahn AG
allerdings unklar die CDU CSU schlägt
jetzt vor Netz und Betrieb zu trennen
und sie trinkt damit in einen Spaltes
Koalitionsvertrags ein das heißt also
FDP und Grüne wollen die auf Trennung
und die SPD will es nicht
soll es ein Wagen Jamaika werden die SPD
sei nun gezwungen sich klar zu
positionieren auch die Eisenbahn und
Verkehrsgewerkschaft EVG lehnt eine
Aufspaltung des Konzerns ab sieht
tarifgebundene Arbeitsplätze gefährdet
wie lange die Bahn wohl noch
Dauerbaustelle bleibt
ja überall das spreche ich jetzt mit dem
Vorsitzenden der Gewerkschaft der
Lokführer kurz gdl-klasse selbst geht ja
selbst auch CDU-Mitglied ist guten
Morgen herzlich willkommen schön guten
Tag sie befürworten den Vorschlag der
cdu/csu den Bahnkonzern aufzuspalten
warum
nun ich bin froh dass der Vorstoß kommt
besser spät als nie sage ich als erstes
zweitens das was der Bahnvorstand und es
in den letzten Jahrzehnten geboten hat
hat zudem geführt was wir hier alle
erleben und Pünktlichkeit und
Zuverlässigkeit und es ist tatsächlich
so dass aktienvorstände nicht
weisungsgebunden sind und im Grunde noch
machen was sie wollen und das ist das
was das Eisenbahnsystem so in Grund und
Boden gefahren hat und deswegen brauchen
wir ein radikalen Schnitt und eine
Veränderung besser spät als sie sagen
sie zu der ganzen Wahrheit gehört dass
die Union selbst 16 Jahre lang sozusagen
in Regierungsverantwortung war und 12
Jahre lang davon den Verkehrsminister
gestellt hat selbst da hätte ja nicht
nur was passieren sollen können sondern
sogar müssen ja da gebe ich Ihnen recht
trotzdem sage ich hier Wedel der Schwanz
mit dem Hund das Management der DB
lobbyiert das Verkehrsministerium seit
Jahrzehnten und zwar in ihre Richtung
und das ist das eigentlich schräge dran
und ich bin froh dass wir jetzt in einer
Regierung sind nur die Grünen und das
Klima Thema nach vorne kommt und das
Eisenbahnsystem gestärkt werden soll
aber es sollten keine Milliarden
Steuergelder in diesem roten Konzern
gepumpt werden und dann schauen wir uns
den Vorschlag mal im Einzelnen an
zentraler Punkt ist ja die Auslagerung
in eine Bundes eigene GmbH was für
Vorteile hätte das denn
und ich sagte bereits aktienfondsstände
sind weisungsungebunden und entscheiden
selbst zum Wohle des Unternehmens
allerdings das Unternehmen hat
mittlerweile fünf mal 30 Milliarden
Schulden und das ist genauso viel in
Euro wie es 1993 entschuldet worden ist
in dem Thema das was jetzt kommt ist
eine GmbH oder kommen soll und bei einer
GmbH entscheidet der Gesellschaft unter
Geschäftsführer aus das heißt es ist
eine rechtlich andere Voraussetzung die
wir als zwingende Grundlage sehen für
eine wirkliche Verbesserung im
Gesamtsystem okay wenn es aber um mehr
Weisungsbefugnisse und auch
Kontrollmöglichkeiten durch den Bund
geht dann sagt sich der ein oder andere
natürlich warum dann nicht gleich
komplett verstaatlichen
nö ich bin kein Träumer die Frage darf
Frau staatlichung stellt sich nicht die
Privatisierung uns 1993 entschieden
worden sie hat auch Folge erzielt wir
haben mehr Verkehr auf der Schiene
insgesamt gesehen gegenüber dem
damaligen Zeitpunkt aber ich bin an der
Stelle klar und deutlich was die
Infrastruktur betrifft erstens muss sie
100% Eigentum des Bundes bleiben die
rechtliche Formen der sie geführt wird
kann auch als GmbH privatrechtlich sein
wir sind heute Aktiengesellschaft 100%
Eigentum des Bundes aber der Durchgriff
der des Eigentümers ist besser gegeben
ohne dass die Politik sich ständig in
jede einzelne Entscheidung einmischen
muss gut dann noch mal ganz konkret zu
den Vorteilen wenn man diese Pläne denn
befolgen würde denn letztlich was unsere
Zuschauer und Zuschauer damit die Kunden
potenziellen Kunden der Deutschen Bahn
interessiert was davon merkt der Kunde
bis jetzt merkt der Kunde eine
städtischen Verschlechterung
die entscheidende Komponente ist was
merken wir bisher und ich stetige
Verschlechterung der Pünktlichkeit eine
stetige Verschlechterung der
Zuverlässigkeit um das ist aufwärts geht
müssen wir viel mehr investieren
allerdings sind die vergangenen
Investitionen teilweise nicht abgerufen
worden Milliarden sind nicht abgerufen
worden und nicht verbaut worden und auch
die Milliarden die eingepflegt worden
sind in den Konzern sind weltweit
inaktivitäten versickert die nichts mit
dem Eisenbahnsystem in Deutschland zu
tun haben und jetzt ist die Entscheidung
in diese Richtung genau die richtige die
Infrastruktur GmbH mit allen drei
Komponenten Energie Netz und Station und
Service zusammenzuführen damit weniger
Schnittstellen zu haben eine bessere
Funktionsfähigkeit übrigens auch weniger
oberheit hat sich um jemand die Frage
beantwortet für was für 3.500 oberste
Führungskräfte brauchen nicht für die
führende Eisenbahn in Deutschland
sondern für weltweite Aktivitäten und
das muss ein Ende haben wir haben gerade
Beitrag den grünen Abgeordneten Matthias
Gastl gesehen der sagte offenbar haben
die also in Bezug auf die Union nicht
mitbekommen dass wir einen Großteil von
dem was da vorgeschlagen wird bereits
umsetzen also inwieweit unterscheidet
sich dieser neue Vorschlag von dem was
eigentlich im Koalitionsvertrag drin
steht den siehe damals also so vorgelegt
wurde auch als positives Signal für die
eisenbahnbranche bezeichnet hatten nun
der Unterschied ist dass wir bis jetzt
von Verkehrsminister wir sind keine
Entscheidung haben und auch die Grünen
können nicht für sich in Anspruch nehmen
das ist eine Entscheidung zur
Allgemeinwohl in orientierten
Infrastruktur gibt das heißt es steht
eine Entscheidung aus am 1.12 24 soll
die stehen und die der Kasse ist knackt
ist in welche Rechtsform findet die
Infrastruktur in die Zukunft hinein
statt wir könnten Milliarden in dieses
System einpflegen ohne dass Europa
rechtlich wir Probleme bekommen wenn der
finanzkreislauf geschlossen bleiben und
die Infrastruktur für sich gesehen nicht
mehr Gewinn abgeführt und beherrschte
Tochter des DBAG Konzerns ist und darum
dreht sich der Geldfluss im Konzern hat
in Vergangenheit dazu geführt dass man
sich auch mit anderen Aktivitäten
Vergnügen konnte und das muss ein Ende
haben die Eisenbahner Gewerkschaft EVG
sieht durch die Zerschlagung der Bahnen
tarifgebundenen Arbeitsplätze gefährdet
können Sie das Problem sehen
nachvollziehen das ist der purpanz der
immer wieder aufgebaut wird die
Eisenbahn und Verkehrsgewerkschaft hat
über die Jahrzehnte die Vorhaben des
Vorstandes aller unterstützt geduldet
und zugestimmt dass diese Entwicklung so
stattgefunden hat wie sie stattgefunden
hat und von daher ist die Position
erstens nicht neu zweitens eine reine
Droge werde es gibt keine Angst zum
Arbeitsplätze wir haben Fachkräftemangel
wir fehlen uns fehlen Lokführer und für
den Zugbegleiter und für den
Fahrdienstleiter wer sollte Angst um den
Arbeitsplatz haben die Verwaltung wenn
ja von mir aus gern denn da haben wir
eindeutig zu viele häklinge und so wenig
Indianern wird
das der Vorsitzende der Gewerkschaft der
Lokführer GDL vielen Dank für Ihren
Besuch bei uns im Studio und das
Gespräch